Hello
你听过吃香蕉
吃到出大事的吗
嘿前一段时间
香蕉便宜到不行
一根只要台币2、3块钱
有个女生为了省钱
一天三餐
就香蕉给它过去了
竟然一天吃了
二十一根香蕉
结果当晚就不舒服了
失去意识昏倒
醒来到医院去医生说
钾离子浓度过高
钾中毒
哇惨兮兮哦
我跟你说
不要为了省钱
而赔上健康
待会儿我要告诉你
有三种状况不要吃香蕉
胡乃文开讲啰
我是你的老朋友胡医师
这集要跟你分享
3状况别吃香蕉
嘿恐致命
1时段吃香蕉
止饿又好眠
香蕉和两物一起煮
暖肠通便
服用1种降压药
注意要少吃香蕉
嘿我跟你说
香蕉可不是那随便的水果
它里面钾的元素
就是potassium很强大
能把你体内
多余的盐份排掉
让血压更稳定
心脏也不会太累
血压容易高高低低的人
吃个香蕉
能够调整血压
吃多少
1天吃半根就好了
半根大概就是
95公克不到100克
又安全又有用
谁不适合吃香蕉呢
请注意
正在吃保钾型降压药的人
香蕉要少吃
避免血钾过高
一般降压药
就大概没啥问题
那还有粉丝会问
血压高的人能吃香蕉
血糖高的人能不能吃呢
Of course
美国糖尿病协会建议
糖友们可以适量吃香蕉
因为香蕉的纤维能稳定血
糖糖 友们
吃香蕉还有个小技巧
就是吃那种
还没完全熟的
带点绿色的那种香蕉
这样的香蕉啊
升糖指数比较低
能更好的控制血糖
不过血糖高的人
一次不要吃超过半根
份量要抓好喔
每天吃香蕉竟然吃到昏迷
3种状况不要吃
你去超商能喝到
韩国的香蕉牛奶
去夜市可以吃到
去夜市可以
香蕉人人都能吃吗
不是啦
三种情况不吃
第一肾功能不好的时候
第二脾胃虚寒的时候
第三正在咳嗽的时候
最好不要吃
肾不好的人
为什么不能多吃香蕉
因为香蕉啊
它钾含量很高
每100公克就有368毫克
满多的
对慢性肾病或是
血钾偏高的人来说
吃了可能
引发生命的危机
有一个真实案例
一个太太啊
大约60岁
她有三高和肾脏病
每天都会吃一根香蕉
有一天
钾离子竟然飙到7.2
当场昏迷紧急送医
哇怎么会这样呢
钾太高会引发心律不整
严重的时候
心脏完全没反应
还好医师施打药物之后
她醒是醒过来了
之后透过洗肾
顺利的把钾降下来
所以如果你家里人
有肾脏不好
一定要提醒他
不要贪吃香蕉
赔了命就不好啰
第2 脾胃虚寒的人不要
吃香蕉 是寒性食物
如果你容易
拉肚子胃痛胃酸过多
甚至于消化性的溃疡
就不要吃香蕉
吃了会更严重
冬天手脚冰冷脸色苍白
嘴唇淡白的人
淡淡的白色的人
更要少碰香蕉
免得肠胃不舒服
以前阿嬷们常说
筋骨不好的人
不能吃香蕉
为什么
其实也是和脾胃有关系
脾胃功能比较弱的人
身体水份代谢就不太好
关节容易僵硬
动作不灵活
所以香蕉也不能吃太多喔
第3 咳嗽
什么水果不能
吃香蕉
因为香蕉会生痰
加重咳嗽
像是橘子鸭肉冰品
这些食物咳嗽的时候
也暂时不要吃
焦虑睡不好
这个时间吃香蕉
睡得香香
你知道吗
这样一根香蕉
就有10毫克的色胺酸
色胺酸是什么好东西
色胺酸进入了大脑以后
先变成所谓的快乐因子
血清素
再转成助眠的荷尔蒙
褪黑激素
能够让你更快的入睡
更能延长深层的
睡眠的时间
让你一觉到天亮
什么时候吃香蕉
助眠最有效
建议你下午3、4点的时候
吃香蕉最好
这个时候肚子有一点点饿
你是不是
正想来一片饼干啊
不要吃啦
不要吃饼干
你放下零食
来吃一根香蕉
坐办公室的人吃香蕉
不沾手很方便
一打开就能吃了
能够止饥饿
晚上还能睡得很香
是不是很棒的零食选择
吃香蕉难通便
和两物一起煮暖肠通便
一位网友分享
他喝了超商推出的
香蕉火龙果牛奶
肠道超顺畅
简直就是肠道的外送
但如果你吃香蕉
肠道还是一点都没动
别担心
试试这个小偏方
你准备一根青皮的香蕉
不是这种黄皮的啊青皮的
再拿3片这个陈皮
陈皮啊就是橘子皮
在药房里头
可以买得到的东西
适量的像这个冰糖
煮成陈皮香蕉汤
暖暖的喝下去
帮助肠道活络起来
这一碗汤能够通便
润肺理气
大人小孩都可以喝
是不是蛮棒的
青皮香蕉温中润肠
帮助排便不燥
就大便不燥会润一点
陈皮又能够理气消滞
让肠道动起来
冰糖还能够润喉养肺
你会问我
体质虚寒的人
不是不能吃香蕉吗
没错但是食物真的很神奇
香蕉煮过之后
它的寒性就给去掉了一点
变得温和一些
这样一来
即便手脚冰冷
脾胃虚寒的人
也可以放心喝它一碗吧
香蕉清热解毒全身是宝
用它治腹痛皮肤痒
你有没有听过阿嬷说
失恋爱吃香蕉皮了
听起来好像是笑话对不对
香蕉皮怎么能吃呢
阿嬷可没有在随便讲喔
香蕉皮真的能吃
还能入药
香蕉皮怎么吃
你逛夜市的时候
有些摊贩会把香蕉皮
炸得香香脆脆的
或是你可以用带皮的香蕉
加牛奶打成香蕉牛奶
要记得喔
皮一定要洗干净
不洗干净怎么能吃对不对
好才能够避免农药残留
古人早就知道
香蕉皮的厉害
把香蕉皮当成药材
广东中药记载
香蕉皮炒一炒煮水喝
能治肠胃炎引起的
突发腹痛
香蕉皮煮水拿来擦洗
能够止皮肤痒
舒缓红疹
香蕉叶也有妙用
太平圣惠方里头记载说
可以把香蕉叶研磨成粉
加上姜汁来调匀
涂在肿胀或小脓包上面
能够消肿止痛喔
再来说说香蕉根
备急千金要方
它记载
香蕉根很寒凉
用来清热解毒
专治因为火气过盛
而长出的脓疮
也就是我们现在讲的痘痘对不对
和发炎等等
你看小小一根香蕉
从皮果肉叶子还有到根
全身都是宝
所以下次吃香蕉
记得香蕉皮不要乱丢
不只是会让人滑倒
还浪费好东西啦
香蕉运动前
还是运动后吃比较好呢
你有没有
发现很多运动员
运动到一半
就拿出一根香蕉
大口咬下
那可是他们的能量
补给秘密武器呀
香蕉要在运动前吃
还是运动后吃
哪个比较好呢
其实两个时间都有好处
运动前30分钟
到一个小时吃香蕉
有天然的糖份钾
能够快速补充能量
让你不会运动到一半
哈哈没力气了
或者是抽筋了
运动后1个小时吃香蕉呢
能补回流失的钾和糖份
帮助肌肉恢复减少酸痛
提醒你哦
如果你是在做高强度运动的人
运动前只要吃半根香蕉就好
太多容易觉得胃胀不舒服